a viewer wrote in via email should they
do jury duty
i think this is a great question and the
answer to that is unequivocally yes
number one not only is it your civic
duty to make sure that
the government doesn't overreach and
that you protect everyone's rights which
in turn protects everyone else's rights
but it's also an incredibly fascinating
experience every time i've done jury
duty
i am lucky to be there and here's one
secret that you might actually not know
about jury duty which is that in many
jurisdictions
the judge is given a list of the jurors
who gets
paid for their time on jury duty and
often judges bend over backwards to make
sure that people who aren't compensated
for their time on the jury
are not selected because that can be a
huge hardship for the jurors
but if you are compensated for your time
by your employer then you're more likely
to be on jury duty and of course
it makes it more likely that you can
fulfill your duties so in answer to your
question yes you should do jury duty so
i'll see you
in court